and click
so Patty's not able to log on and she
was going to introduce you because she
knows you very well and the background
um
is your receptionist
um Becca they are close by
yes
um is is it possible for Becca to
introduce you
yes are you willing to do that Becca
absolutely
thank you so much
you are welcome of course the lighting
on my side is not that great oh you look
wonderful
well thank you so much are you ready to
get started yes ma'am all right well my
name is Becca Dukes I'm a certified
holistic health coach with the Institute
of ballistic health I am also Dr
wallach's personal assistant in helping
him get this message around the world
and we are so very very honored to be
included in this carol as you know the
you're the CEO of doula family Legacy
and that is so important where you can
take a birth
from start to finish keeping it in the
home keeping it as much natural as
absolutely possible and that's what Dr
Wallach is all about so he started out
very young with having some difficulties
and through his research as with a
Bachelor of Science in agriculture going
into veterinarian medicine taking that
degree as a pathologist around the world
and doing over 452
actually it's over 2 20 000 autopsies on
452 different species including humans
almost 2 000 of those were on children
in Keyshawn China trying to figure out
why are these kids dying so young
why
and he was able to do that through
some amazing Insight that he was gifted
with from the Lord and Savior so it is
my honor and privilege to introduce to
you Dr Joel Wallach who took all of that
information and decided you know what I
want to be a better service
to the people so he went back to school
and became a naturopathic physician he
didn't find what he was looking for as
far as how he could treat his clients
his patients so he formulated what he
had found as being needed in his
research into the products that he
represents and now
just is free to tell the world so
without further Ado I present to you Dr
Joel Wallach okay well thank you so much
Rebecca and thank you so much uh see
here Hattie right yeah Hattie and Carol
yeah and Carol okay thank you thank you
and basically Rebecca did a great job
and you know in the introduction I'm
just in a little bit there
um
by the time I was
um five years old I was um you know in
kindergarten at that time and getting
violent and uh I beat up the teacher and
I'd beat up the kids and I was very
strong because I grew up in a farm and
could throw bales of hay and all this
kind of stuff and over a period of five
years by the time I was nine years old I
had seen 20 doctors my parents had taken
me to 20 doctors and this was a
combination of now there's somebody in
the lower screen dancing and throwing
around and tipping and I don't know who
the heck that is but they're very
distracting
yeah
okay okay thank you okay and so
um by the time I was nine years old I
had seen 20 doctors and they were going
to institutionalize me in a hospital
Ward was for uh incorrigible kids
there's a plight way of saying it and um
I'm sitting on the end of my bed and my
parents are packing my clothes on Friday
night because on Monday they're going to
take me to this Hospital slash prison
okay essentially what it was
okay and
um
I'm thinking to myself why am I having
these problems nobody else around here
is having these problems why me so the
next morning
uh it was Saturday morning I went out to
the barn and I threw my
Wheaties and oatmeal to the chickens and
I filled my cereal bowl full of the
Alfalfa pellets that were fortified with
vitamins and minerals to our calves and
I put them in my cereal bowl fill it
with milk and had it for breakfast did
it again on Sunday had it for breakfast
did again on Monday have her breakfast
by Monday afternoon I was cured under
two and a half days of taking these
nutrients in the Alfalfa pellets all the
vitamins and minerals
I was cured and it was like shaking
everybody up I didn't say anything to
anybody
but you know we'd go to church and
everybody's whispering and pointing at
me because that wasn't disruptive
anymore
and they were telling stories of how
it's getting better and so forth after a
couple of weeks in a month or so people
are coming to me and say I have diabetes
can you help me
um I have arthritis can you help me I'm
only nine years old I don't even know
what those things are okay so I had to
start reading some of the animal books
that we had on the farm on animal
diseases
and so forth and figured out why we
didn't have those things in animals
because we're giving them all these
vitamins and minerals to prevent
and cure those diseases in humans
they're just getting medicine to treat
the symptoms I'm nine years old but I
figured that difference out between
preventing and treating symptoms okay
that was a big Revelation to me when I
was nine years old
and
um so to make a long story short Rebecca
did a great job
um my first scientific publication I was
working my way through
veterinary school
1963 I was a junior in veterinary school
University Missouri
and
um all the professors were gone I was
working my way through their High School
by working in the Pathology Department
this farmer came to he brought 50 dead
Lambs to me
about 50 deadlams they're only six
months old
beautiful
great wool and he was going to take 500
of them to
be sheared a couple of days after
Christmas and then after the New Year
they're gonna take them all for
Slaughter
well that night 500 died
they're perfectly normal the day before
and 500 died and he brought me 50 of
them I opened them up their blood was
black
not dark red but black and I said do you
have farms around you yeah we're
surrounded by a foreign
have animals no they all just grow hay
and wheat and I said okay what kind of
fertilizer they use well they all use
nitrate fertilizer because they get paid
by tonnage they don't get paid by the
nutritional value of the food they just
get paid by time so they use nitrogen
fertilizer nitrates so they can get the
maximum tonnage per acre they said okay
well there's your problem all that
nitrate fertilizer is getting into the
water there and these Lambs they all had
goiter they all had big thyroids they'll
head glider and that night when the
temperature dropped they all died of
hypothermia because their thyroids
couldn't support their body temperatures
and that was my first scientific
publication I was only 23 years old the
professors didn't want anything to do
with it so I was I got it published in a
national Veterinary Journal
and I was working with Marlon Perkins
from the old Mutual Maha Kingdom show
because I was a tough kid and he touched
me to protect him from animals that bite
and stuff like that so he trusted me and
so
um he sent me to South Africa in
unfalosian game reserves because the
White Rhino were all dying and he says
find out why they're dying wall like
okay so
um I I had to do two things he said
catch as many as you can find a way to
get him here so we can save as many as
we can because there's only 350
Financial head count Left Alive at that
time in South Africa 350.
to make a long story short in two years
I caught 200 of them sent them here and
I was checking their blood and you know
examining the ones that died and doing
autopsies on them and so forth and
figured out what was happening I was
figuring out what was happening
um the farmers would come in and they
move into the territories as white
rhinos had been in for thousands of
years millions of years
which had all the minerals in the soil
because the volcanoes and floods and
everything and they were being pushed
down into the desert and didn't get any
nutrition
and so they're all starving to death
okay so we built two big main
um wild animal parks for them we put in
the traditional salt blocks we built
ponds for them and everything like that
and multiple mineral fertilizers for
them and everything and they began to
reproduce
um just last year the count was 21
000.
so we're so proud that we did a great
job on that one that was my first
um pathology postdoctoral Fellowship was
that with the white rhino project
and to make a long story shark and
Perkins gets a grant on that on that
study I did in the 500 people died
they've got published when I was gone he
went to Washington University in St
Louis and Dr Barry Connor PhD in biology
and they took my paper and they got a 21
million dollar Grant from NIH National
Institutes and health to study
pollution in zoo animals because they
wanted to find a zoo animal in each of
the big cities of the world it could be
kind of like the canaries in the mine
for
for coal miners so if gases are terrible
things would happen in the cities the
animals in the zoo would die and we knew
to get out and so that was my job was to
find to do the pathology of these zoo
animals so I did
um
over 20 000 autopsies I'm proud of my
thesis is in the Smithsonian Institute
is a National Treasure but they found
out that there were no exactly
transmitted diseases natin created the
new science of epigenetics the death of
the genetic theories transmission
um I do have
a copy a book here okay
oh wow the death of the Gen Theory this
is a summary of my thesis which is in
the Smithsonian is doing still you can
go
um you know and ask and they'll show you
a copy of it but they have guards with
it because they they sell for 25 000
each
and so they people want to steal them so
they don't have to have a guard with
them so we came out with a summary of it
this is me uh at Emory University at the
Yorkies Primary Center where I found in
1976 I found the first non-human case of
cystic fibrosis supposed to be one of
the most terrible genetic birth defects
physical roses and
um
got it I knew what it was but they
weren't going to believe me because it's
supposed to be a human birth defect a
genetic thing so I took slides and sent
them to five different medical schools
and I said look
I think this is cisiobrosis what do you
think I didn't tell him it was from a
monkey I just told him I think it was
his hair brosis and a couple weeks I got
back on their letterheads yes this is a
classic example of physical Rose says
then I sent him another letter because
we're talking 1976 you know I didn't
have any emails and texts and that kind
of stuff back then
so it took a couple of weeks here a
couple weeks there and
um I you know sent him a letter saying
well thank you this is the first
non-human case of citibrosis I think I
can probably you know find some more and
maybe do lab studies on them finding out
how we can help the kids they were so
excited about it and then I got
permission to do biopsies and the other
24 baby monkeys that they're grooming to
send a space okay at the Yorkies primate
Center which is Emory University okay
and um so I got biopsies of them and
they all had cystic fibrosis
okay so I knew that there was something
going on with the diet there okay and I
got that all done I got it ready to go
and I was going to give it at a national
meeting
of um the National Institutes of Health
and when they found out I was going to
say that physical brosis was not a
genetic this is the simple nutritional
efficiency they fired me summarily they
fired me okay and shut down the project
and so I went into all these events
looking for something to do and I got a
job teaching nutrition at the
naturopathic College up in Portland
Oregon I said well since I'm here you
know teaching nutrition why don't I get
a degree in nature Panic medicine at the
same time so they gave me some credit
for some of my courses in very medicine
and Agriculture and all that kind of
stuff
and I took courses and I graduated in
1982 as a nature doctor from NC national
college and age Family Medicine Portland
Oregon very proud of that
and so
um I'm treating
people all over the place and I'm
noticing that there's so many problems
that are just simple nutritional
efficiencies that doctors are saying
whether they're a naturopathic doctor or
a medical doctor or a chiropractor uh
they're all saying it's a genetic thing
but they weren't okay they're just
simple electrical efficiencies because
I'd done so many autopsies by that time
eventually I did over 32 000 autopsies
okay and it's one of those things where
when you do that much you kind of figure
out some things
and
the whole idea here was to get
information to people why we didn't have
those problems in the animal industry
why we don't have health insurance for
animals that's because we're putting all
these vitamins and metals into their
Alfalfa pellets or preventing all those
diseases wow okay so I said why do we do
that for people
okay so we're not having to treat those
diseases okay and so that's why you
don't hear much about birth defects in
animals because all the food they're
getting whether a dog or a cat or a cow
or a horse are sheep or pig or chicken
or a duck or a goose or okay guinea fowl
they're all getting their vitamins and
minerals and their pellets
and so the embryos are protected
yeah okay so I said okay that's what we
got that's where you got to go and
I began to lecture in various events and
things on that subject and
it's uh it created quite a monster okay
and
um because nobody had ever thought in
those terms that all those diseases they
were the same as genetic well they have
three people in their family with
diabetes Well they're all eaten the same
way I went back and I went back and I
went back and I went back and I found
out why all this was happening I found
out while this was happening this is all
happening
okay
because of electricity
the bioelectrical charge within the body
no oh more simple than that
okay for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years what we're using for
fuel
wood and coal yeah and what would you
what would we do with the wood ashes
Nicole ashes every morning
you would put it back into the garden
you put them in the garden very good and
from the fireplace you put them in the
garden from the stove you put them in
the garden and we were poor farmers and
so we couldn't afford expensive
um spices and things like that for our
food so Grandma used to take the wood
ashes and the coal ashes and put them in
our stew and our cereal and our soup and
so forth we're getting our our
taste that way but we're also getting
the minerals or in the wood area it
turns out the wood ashes and coal ashes
are 95 to 98 by weight minerals
wow carbon
okay now at three o'clock in the
afternoon I know the exact moment
because I traced it down at three
o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 on Pearl Street in
New York City and the bluff overlooking
the construction Brooklyn Bridge Town
assassin pulled the switch on
electricity
okay okay within 18 years by 1900 we had
50 new diseases nobody ever seen before
and people were dying like flies and
doctors are saying oh it's all a genetic
thing it's all an environmental thing
okay
no
wow
the Hell's Kitchen named after the bad
place in New York City where every bad
thing happens
right well that's why I titled this book
because it shows the transition from
wood and cold as fuel we're here all or
minerals for thousands and thousands of
years okay okay going to electricity how
many ashes are left over when you use
electricity
none
and so there's no more minerals going
into the population now nutritional
minerals
do not occur in a uniform blank around
the crust of the earth they current
veins like gold and silver
now the people who lived the longest in
the old days you know like
like uh
um Methuselah who lived me 969 okay he
and other people like his kids and so
forth and many other people like Noah
lived in the lands flowing with milk and
honey
I'm thinking okay
they didn't have herds of cows
how could they have milk flowing down
these Hills and everything when there's
no cattle herds and everything they're
not talking about cows in the Garden of
Eden and stuff like that or goats or
anything like that what's going on well
it turns out
the land is Flowing of milk and honey
including the Garden of Eden
or streams coming down from the
mountains
was minerals suspended in them and the
minerals turned the water white because
the minerals were like from from from
the ocean from
um things like Limestone and everything
like that and so it looked like milk
coming down but it was just minerals
suspended in the water and these are the
people who are getting the minerals who
are living the longest didn't have
diseases
it's fascinating isn't that neat okay so
I'm thinking okay this is this track
record here of humanity is a well well
documented
and once we went to electricity all that
went away including when they went to a
hydroelectric we damned up all the
rivers okay for hydroelectric now that
was even worse
have you ever heard of bottomland
yes I have but I don't know exactly what
it is okay well bottom line was
extremely valuable because it would
flood Every Spring
when the when you know the snow would
melt up in the mountains and the the
streams would get bigger and very
violent and everything and bringing down
again the minerals and the silt and
everything from the mountains and go
into the fields for the farmers and
Farmers loved it because it would
re-fertilize the fields every year and
they didn't have to pay for it was just
a natural thing that had been going on
since the beginning of time and
when the flood waters would recede
they'd go out and plow in all that silt
into the fields and they'd get
fertilizer for nothing and the bottom
line so that's why bottom line was so
valuable they've been going on since
long before man came along okay
well now we have these dams damming up
all the rivers no more bottom land
oh and electricity no more wood ashes
and so that's why we have all these
health problems they're not genetic and
my thesis is in the Smithsonian
Institute as a National Treasure because
they showed there are no gently
transmitter diseases
okay and they're all just simple
nutritional efficiency diseases and then
we began to say okay we're going to do
for people like we've done for Animals
we're gonna make all these programs for
them
and they don't get arthritis they don't
get high blood pressure they don't get
diabetes they don't get Alzheimer's
they'll always remember where there's
food they'll find it right
and they're not going to get heart
disease they're not going to get asthma
they're not going to get
um psoriasis they're not going to get
lupus they're not getting kidney failure
and they're not getting all that stuff
and they have to be on dialysis like we
do because they're getting all the
vitamins and minerals by putting them in
their Alfalfa pellets they were feeding
them
they said we got to do the same thing
for people and that's how we started and
created all of our programs and
um we started of course with our plant
minerals that was made us different
because we had these liquid plant
minerals and of course they come in in
the bottles hard bottles liquid plant
Metals I think I have some here
they come in bottles like this okay okay
and there's 75 to 78 thank you they're
75 to 78 minerals
because they're coming from the
volcanoes okay and in each of these
places there's eight places on Earth
where we get them 75 to 78 minerals when
we started youngevity okay it was
actually American ones you to start with
um and we
um were having a hard time and I didn't
want to be like everybody else just
grinding up Limestone and having say
seven eight nine ten different minerals
in there and we're literally physically
going around the world we're finding all
these places around coral reefs that
have 75 minerals around the reefs okay
we're finding all this this mineral
stuff in these mountains in the
himalayans we had 75 to 78 minerals in
them because that's what we want for us
we don't want the eight minerals we want
the 75 minerals yeah the hunzas their
life expectancies 120. our life
expectancy is 73.
okay the record in recent times on the
industrialized world is in France a
Woman by the name of Gene kelmet died in
she was 122 years 164 days
wow
amazing
and so this is what we can expect we can
expect 120 years it's biblical in the
Old Testament and God said man's ear
shall be
120 right that that's because they knew
about the land flowing with milk and
honey okay all those minerals coming
down and the creeks and everything okay
so this is why we took the direction we
did and we said okay we're going to do
for our kids we're doing for our animals
and start putting all these nutrients
into baby Farmers okay because
um I'm just doing all these all the time
you see all these birth defects and all
these babies all these terrible birth
defects and everything and I said we
don't have those birth defects in
animals anymore because they're putting
all these nutrients in the mother's feed
and so we got to do that for people as
well
and so we created what we called the
Healthy Start pack that had 90s 90
essential nutrients and 16 minerals 16
vitamins 12 amounts of Three fatty acids
and that's where we started and to make
a long story short
um
we began to add things to that okay and
we got the healthy Brandon heart pack
which had
um 215 nutrients including the 90 and we
had to change our name because foreign
countries wouldn't let us in because
they didn't want American Longevity so
we changed it to youngevity yeah okay so
we could get into these foreign
countries and get this information out
there and so our goal was to prevent all
these birth defects because none of them
are genetic
and so what we learned was you have to
do this
before the mothers go through puberty
oh wow
she's got to get all these nutrients
before the A's are being formed
okay okay then she's got to get him for
her self and then she's got to get them
you know forever and then
um when she's
um pregnant she can't say oh I missed
two periods I better start taking some
vitamins middle that's too late
it's too late okay because that embryo
and her egg and her ovaries should be
getting the nutrients for at least years
before
those eggs are
populated okay and so you need to start
long before they realize they've missed
two cycles or three Cycles that's way
too late we can prevent every Bird's
effect you can name 99.9 of them are
simple nutritional deficiencies there's
a few of them where are poisons you know
like um
feel alcohol syndrome and that kind of
stuff right okay and then there's other
poisons they might get in well water or
something like that but for the most
part 99 of all birth defects are caused
by chronic nutritional efficiencies in
the mother long long long long long
before that conception took place
okay so we have to go back generations
and start
for this kid so that their kids and
their grandkids and great-grandkids will
all be good sure okay so that's how this
works and so we have learned we can
prevent all birds effects or another
genetic they're another autoimmune
that freaks doctors out okay but they
don't they don't get taught that in
school they get taught that everything
is genetic don't you can't fix it just
give them pain relief and they're happy
that's why the medical system works the
way it works because they still believe
that there's all these genetic things
and I'll tell you a great story and
Rebecca has been working on a big big
thing uh it's going to be coming out
pretty soon okay
we're very very proud of that we worked
with a famous
um basketball player Theo Ratliff have
you ever heard of him not myself no okay
well Theo Ratliff I'm back oh this is a
20th year anniversary that we started
working with him he just turned 50. and
he was 24 years old
um he had a 35 million dollar contract
okay with the Atlanta Hawks and after
the first year he had bone to bone
arthritis and bosnies he had the
cartilage slipping off his hips he
fractured his shooting arm wrist on the
right hand they took his contract away
from him to say bye there's nothing to
do for our doctors say you need
artificial knees and artificial hips you
could have a artificial arm and all this
kind of stuff you can't use you anymore
bye and so his Pastor brought him to me
20 years ago
now examined him looked at him talked to
him I said I think I can fix you and he
started laughing this guy's seven foot
tall and I'm only five foot two
okay I said well give me a chance okay I
won't charge anything for my fees or
anything because I think I can help you
so make a long story short I came up
with what we call the healthy bone and
dried pack for him it was our Healthy
Start pack with a 90 essential nutrients
in it but I added our first collagen
product which was glucogel okay which is
collagen from beef added to that we
called it the healthy Bone and Joint
pack gave him that
okay for his body weight and then I also
came up three months later was rebound
or his fourth shrink okay which has 100
nutrients in it 75 minerals and 25
vitamins comes in sticks there's 30
sticks in a box uh comes in canisters or
some countries it only let the cancers
in they don't want the cans or anything
um we also have the cans and it's the
100 nutrients in it but it also has
carbonation so I like to pop the tops on
them
um two of them night before I go to bed
put them in the refrigerator or they're
flat in the morning all the bubbly is
gone okay so I have to worry about
carbonation neutralizing my stomach acid
and all that kind of stuff right those
are all the things you got to think
about yes absolutely yeah should I make
a long story short we rebuild him
uh I don't know less than a year he gets
his contract back he plays for 11 more
years makes a hundred million dollars
because of the healthy Bone and Joint
pack and glucose and rebound
and so we're going to tell the story and
have we have great pictures and all
kinds of stuff uh and Rebecca's putting
all this together this is gonna be a
podcast coming out here pretty quick
it's going to be free to the average
person okay oh that's wonderful because
we can prevent
and reverse all Quote degenerate bone
diseases joint diseases non-emergency
number autoimmune none of them are due
to old age or just all due to
nutritional deficiencies and so we're
very very excited when you get an
organization like yours where we can
help young families but they've got to
and of course they'll pay wholesale
prices and the Beautiful Thing of this
they get on auto ship I will pay the
shipping and even gets better when they
retire or die their organization goes to
their kids yeah Legacy yeah if you work
for a big Corporation and you work in a
you know multi-billion dollar office for
25 years all this kind of stuff when you
retire you die does your family get that
job
no oh no okay so even if you only do
work with us one night a week or two
days a week or something like that or
just on the weekends it's worth doing
because it's going to benefit every
generation of your family
and it's going to prevent all these
birds effects we're going to repair kids
that are born with birth defects are
repairable most of them repairable even
after they're born
okay
no yeah when you have cleft palate you
need surgery you have spina bifida you
need surgery but those are preventable
when you have a baby who's born
with um oh
you know something like um
they they oh mustard history that's
another one that I got rid of I worked
with Jerry Lewis Jerry's Kids uh most
history supposed to be against genetic
disease right he's been 46 years he
spent 46 years he raised 2.6 billion
dollars through the Telethon for them
and he was my hero so I worked with him
and volunteered my time with him for
many years and then we figured out what
was causing muscular dystrophy in humans
and we told him and brought him to
um a place uh
in in the southern part of the central
United States
okay
and
um
we brought him to these Amish
communities where they had a very high
rate of Massachusetts because there was
no none of these nutrients in the soil
there and they weren't taking vitamins
minerals
so we started giving these kids these
vitamins minerals and we cured these
kids with muscularity doctors would come
and do biopsies and they'd argue with me
they do biopsies and they'd say okay
you're right they don't have it anymore
and so he published it and
he got so excited Jerry Lewis
and so he took it to his was I'll never
forget the date
September 2011 was a Telethon that year
it was Saturday okay
uh says it's he was September
um
I think it was fourth okay 2011.
he took them
the prevention and cure for much history
some early fired him put a gag order on
him so he couldn't say anything to
anybody
and they shut down the Telethon it was
supposed to schedule for the next day
and that was the end of the Telethon and
Jerry Lewis was most Judiciary and that
was one that was one of the biggest
things we would watch yeah it all
disappeared because they didn't want to
find the Cure they just want to keep
raising the money
okay so we said okay we took Jerry Lewis
and we let him know we're going to
continue and we've we came up with the
college wrenching cure for for musk
history so I'm the guy who found the
cross-ranging cure for Cystic abrosis
I'm the guy who found the College of
engine cure for
most of those feet I'm a guy that found
the cause and prevention for son of a
death syndrome now you remember what
doctors were saying caused sediment
death syndrome
yes what was that
I don't know what was causing it but
they blame the mothers for laying on the
babies and suffocating them remember
laying them on their tummies or laying
them on their back or laying them on
there laying on them and suffocating
that's what the doctor said over and
over and over for a thousand not a
thousand but hundreds of years okay
right so
we started curing those kids was
Muscular Dystrophy and suddenly now we
didn't have seven dead syndrome anymore
now we couldn't get these nutrients put
into the baby fertils Enfamil and
similar because the medical doctor stood
in the way and said those minerals are
poisons you can't put them in baby
formulas
so I took my personal money I sold a
bunch of my family's property
we went to eight federal courts sued the
FDA Food and Drug Administration okay
right on all eight cases we forced them
to put these nutrients into baby Farmers
within 90 days all of a sudden the death
syndrome stopped almost history stopped
all cigarbrosis stopped you haven't
heard much about scissors anymore have
you no you haven't heard much about
Moshi anymore have you
syndrome if I once in a while there'll
be one pop-up because some mothers out
there drinking goat's milk or something
like that instead of taking all the
vitamins and minerals
okay but for the most part I got rid of
those three diseases just by getting
these baby by putting these minerals
into baby forms it cost me a million
dollars of my own money in in federal
courts to get it done
so we know how to deal with this stuff
and we're here Ms is that similar to
I'm sorry Ms is that similar with Ms is
very easy to prevent and reverse all
those process is very simple nutritional
deficiency and it's going to freak you
out when I tell you what nutrient is
missing when you have MS you know so
demolition right
of of the brain and spinal cord well
myelin is made out of what
I don't know myelin is 100 cholesterol
who told you to give up cholesterol
the doctors
bam you got it okay they are the ones
who created MMS
wow by getting everybody off of
cholesterol because they made a mistake
a hundred years ago saying
cholesterol causes plaque in your
arteries right it's a thousand percent
wrong
cholesterol doesn't cause plaque in your
arteries it's fried chicken and fried
potatoes
wow is it that inflammation from that
burnt fat okay now we came up with a
program we call I-26
gives you 25 of your daily requirement
cholesterol and they're chewable which
tastes like vanilla ice cream and kids
love them
I take two at lunch time every day
they're about the size of a quarter
diameter they're about a half a
millimeter thick chewable kids love them
okay they take two for lunch I have
three eggs poached eggs or sauce
scramble and butter for breakfast and
three for dinner along with my steaks
and
in my bison and all that other stuff
um
and so forth and let's see here
Ms is easy to get rid of gambarre
syndrome which is just Ms for the spinal
cord okay okay and then there's a new
one out
f t d frontal temporal dementia which is
a type of Alzheimer's disease in which
the front of your brain is all screwed
up the sides your brain are all screwed
up but the back half your brain's normal
okay
okay so we give them our I-26 we have
them take three eggs twice a day
soft scrambling butter or soft boiled
not hard-boiled not fried
and we get them on the I-26 we get them
on the 90th Century nutrients they held
the brain in hard pack MSM synaptives so
the brain cells can talk to each other
Alzheimer's goes away
Ms goes away
FTD goes away
um what's the one where they have all
the tremors
oh the Parkinson's Parkinson's yeah that
one goes away too Parkinson's disease
will go away
bring bring me your how they say bring
me your
foreigns we came up with a product
called also in addition to the I-26 we
have synaptive which is a piece about
chemistry that's needed for your brain
cells to talk to each other okay take
three of those twice a day okay also
they need circulation of the brain don't
forget the ultimate daily classic can't
have three words ultimate daily classic
tablets three of those twice today per
100 pounds of body weight get the
circulation of the brain the synaptive
your I-26 your three eggs twice a day
and your 90 essential nutrients all
those diseases go away or in the first
place you'll never even get them
wow and five
in five weeks I'll be 84 years old and I
don't have any of those problems
you're just a young spring chicken
you're a teenager compared to what you
think yeah most people think I'm in my
50s or early 60s when they look at me
they can't believe I'm 84 years old
so
um this is very simple stuff and so they
need to start long before they've missed
two cycles okay we need to start them
okay when they're
in preschool one there was a couple
years back well it's been quite a few
years back there was a poster that that
you had created for prenatal care and
the nutrients required and how to I have
I have searched high and low for that
poster and I don't know where to find it
do you still print that out well I'll
have to look
yeah Beck and I can find one I'm sure
we need to make the new poster saying to
prevent birth defects in your family
your children
yes or they go into kindergarten need to
start taking the 90 essential nutrients
and getting rid of the bad foods
maximize absorption that's when they
need to start you don't start after
you've missed two cycles
no
you know the one of the things that I
noticed uh Dr Wallach
um been doing bursts for 43 years
um and when you're doing the burst
you're just not nurturing the mom and
baby right you're looking at the whole
extended family that's correct and the
extended family I've noticed has had
more and more health issues and that
system is breaking down so the family
unit is breaking down
and it's been Progressive and it's been
I when I would teach childbirth
education I would have the the
grandparents come and attend as well so
they would be getting the information
that they needed to hear and support the
families okay here's here's where it
starts
the the problem starts with the medical
school
okay because they say eat well you get
everything you need don't waste your
money and taking any vitamins but it'll
just eat well get everything you need
now you got a lot of what you needed
when we had wood stoves and fireplaces
because we put the wood ashes into the
gardens into your food you're getting
minerals that way
how many ashes do you eat every day now
none yeah I'm not getting the minerals
anymore
okay now it's one of those things where
um why did in many of the this is a
really wild one why was it that the
uncle remus's and Uncle Tom's you know
the slaves why did they live to be 110
120 130 and the plantation owners were
dying their 40s
implantation owners want to be like
Europeans who just eat nothing but steak
for breakfast lunch and dinner and they
gave their livers in the hearts and the
kidneys oh sure to to the slaves and
they would get the trace minerals that
were stored in the livers yes and that's
why they live so long
okay quarterman's food which happened to
be the gifts of God that's right the
poor managed food that was a gift from
God yeah and so we have to we have to
get our communities all over the world
understanding that they need to do this
okay and one of my favorite diseases
because doctors don't get trained about
this in school is osteoporosis of the
skull have you ever heard of
osteoporosis of the skull no no they
don't teach that to doctors now you have
to appreciate that
um
uh let's see Rebecca and Dr Ramon and I
we came up with a book and a CD it's
called it's all in your head goes into
the 37 different diseases that people
get
you know actually approach physical
this is the book it's all in your head
okay okay uh-huh yeah
this
the Tactical pictures yeah the top
picture is a picture of a normal skull
you see it right obviously you cut the
the crown of the skull off and
yeah
is here okay yes yeah and the skull is a
quarter of an inch sick
the bottom skull is also an autops
they've cut the crown over looking down
the brain but you can see that the skull
is an inch after two inches thick and
that's not bone that is actually
connective tissue because they have
osteoporosis of the skull now there's 12
pairs of cranial nerves
talk about this I talk about that side
there's a spinal cord
and there's have you ever heard of
people who get up at night three four
five ten times a night to urinate and
all that kind of stuff the first thing
that doctors want to do is a biopsy of
their prostate gland right well what
happens when it's a woman urinating 10
times a night she doesn't have a
prostate gland right okay well in this
book we go into all the diseases you get
the 37 diseases you get when you have
approaches it's called squeezing all of
those nerves oh wow you get tinnitus
ringing in the ears
squeezing the auditory branches of the
atrial nerve yet dizziness and balance
problems you fall down break your leg
they treat your broken leg but was
caused by osteoporosis of the skull
squeezing the vestibular Branch to the
atrial nerve and then you get atrial
fibrillation you ever hear afib yes
what's the treatment for AFib
they give medication but I think they
need some potassium and they do ablation
cut your chest open take your heart out
put hot branding irons all over your
heart looking for the place of making
your heart beat irregularly and then
they kill you it has the highest
mortality rate of any medical treatment
and it's not a heart problem it's your
skull squeezing the tenth cranial nerve
causing your regular heartbeat
wow there was somebody on Facebook who
was posting how scared she was because
they were thinking of doing that
procedure on her no no you never contact
you okay and we will we will get her on
the right track and we will solve that
problem we do this thousands of times a
day all over the world
because of that book okay that's
wonderful okay now these are the sort of
things we do and so we we cannot tell
you how happy we are to join with you
because we can eliminate all birth
defects there are no genetic birth
defects there's no autoimmune birth
defects okay
um and Dr Wallach
this this is Hattie my for some reason
my camera isn't coming on
but this is one of the reasons why Carol
and I wanted to do this with you today
because
we truly recognize the importance of
getting this message out
next to the medical schools but also to
duelist and midwives
because you have doulas you have new
wives that also don't have a clue that's
right and they they really need to have
this information because they are
intricately connected with these women
well this they're closer so we need to
we need to be dealing with the midwives
absolutely I'm on your side there okay
absolutely let's do it because the
medical doctors I've had some patients
which would cure some of these health
problems because we we've repaired their
skeletal osteoporosis and they were
telling their doctor
um that their osteoporosis
process called which the doctor didn't
diagnose and the you know the ear nose
and throat doctors had put hearing aids
in their ears and all this kind of stuff
and they didn't need them anymore
because we had cured them
um of the osteoporosis of the skull the
doctors just threw the charts down on
the floor and stomped out of the room he
says I don't have to listen to that crap
is what he said the doctor
okay and so it's one of those things
where let's go to The Midwives let's go
to the nurses let's go to the okay to
where the rubber meets the road okay
exactly exactly and I can't tell you how
thankful we are to be working with you
and um it's one of those things where
um uh you know Rebecca and Milan
we have a big team here
um
and Hattie and I know Hattie right yep
okay and now we have Carol right yes
okay so we're gonna go to work here and
we have the tools we have the books we
have the CDs and people have to
understand and that book we're selling
this book Hell's Kitchen like crazy
because people didn't realize medical
doctors didn't realize that transition
from wood and coal to electricity
suddenly we went away from all the
resourcing minerals we've been using for
millions of years sure sure
um is there a website that our as people
listen to this because I will be posting
it in LinkedIn Facebook and all that is
their website that they can go to
to get your books order your books and
your educational material
yes okay
www.drjwallik.com
www.drjwalk.com okay and if they buy 10
of any one title they get a big discount
okay and
um if they do this as a business
um you know the youngevity thing is a
business and and help other people we
will send them you know a check every
month based on the volume they create
um okay also uh they when they give
seasonal and birthday and graduation
gifts and everything if they give
something to do with their business it's
a tax deduction also when they retire or
die their youngevity business goes to
their family
they continued on whereas if you're
working for a big multi-million dollar
Corporation you work for them for 25
years and you die you retire right do
they get your business no does your
family get your business since you spend
all your life dealing with no okay and
so you know we don't expect you to quit
those very expensive you know we're
getting lots of money from but you know
take one evening take one day a weekend
or something like that and work with us
um this is a big thing and you know
between
um between uh Hattie and Rebecca and
whoever else is needed here
um but don't forget
www.drjwalk.com we do have the health
um
oh you have a newsletter yeah yeah well
this is actually it's a catalog okay
okay it's the health education brochure
educational brochure okay okay and we
also have the certified health coaches
if you want to become a certified health
coach with us okay oh nice this covers
uh 23 best-selling books 100 CDs uh 40
DVDs okay all this kind of stuff and
these are I think these are free okay
you buy a couple books we ship you a
bunch of these or if you're doing what
you're doing you can send you a hundred
of them or something like that get them
in the hands of people
okay
so Dr Wallach I just want I know because
I know you have to go and we are coming
to the end and I so apologize for the
technical difficulties that did not
allow me to be here on time
but this is such a powerful discussion
because
for some reason I keep asking the
question why is it that we don't get the
importance of minerals because we talk
about I just had a friend of mine she
just had a stroke now she's a health
addict she's she does all she eats right
right
and she takes herbs but people don't get
that we must must must must Like Oxygen
we must take minerals yes well that's
just the proceedings before that's what
the books are for okay and of course we
do have a book it's called rare Earth's
been cures tells you how to cut your
hair where to ship it so you can find
out how many nutritional minerals you
have okay it also tells you how many
toxic Metals you have it's called Rare
Earth Venturas chapter 10 11 page 272.
everybody needs to have a hair analysis
once a year okay to find out where
you're at okay and so that's one of
those things that you know you get that
book uh that's that's that's one of
those things you want to keep with the
Bible
the health evaluation course that we
have is centered around Dr wallach's
teachings right and in my mind every
human being should be a health coach why
because every family needs one every
Community needs one
because the the crisis of dis-ease is
too big so I think every human being
should be a health coach and I just want
to put my number out for anybody for
anyone who's interested to just reach
out to 773
-6651-773-704-6651 and we'll give you
all the information that you need but
this is really a very important
um uh I don't I don't know
um
let me interject their most birthday
effects are reversible
all of them are preventable
yeah we have so you have Rosa saying
reverse he hasn't reverse it okay you
have a pressure in reverse you have type
2 diabetes and reverse it type 2
diabetes makes up 90 of diabetic
population I reverse it I can prevent
type 1 diabetes which is a simple
nutritional divisions in the early
embryonic stages
wow
all these are preventable and most of
them are reversible
that's and so we cannot tell you how
much we love it it's you ladies are
getting involved here because you know
you are where the rubber meets the road
yes we
um I know we're coming down we have a
number of people that they would like to
ask a question are you able to stick
around for a couple questions I can take
a couple of questions okay
the um the name of the book for the
minerals again is what's the name of
your book their Earth forbidden cures
Rare Earth forbidden cures and then we
have one mom on the autism
what what's going on with that okay well
your brain requires 90 essential
nutrients okay okay doctors have no
earthy idea what your brain needs all
they want to do is give you medicine
okay and so you need to be eating eggs
not fried not hard boiled you need that
yolk you need the cholesterol 25 of your
brain weight is cholesterol is called
myelin it's a white matter of the brain
25 of your spinal cord is cholesterol
it's a white matter of the spinal cord
okay you need to be eating eggs with
soft scrambled eggs okay if you have
little kids that are too little to be
eating scrambled eggs you know a couple
days old you can give them the um
I-26 the powder okay put that in their
formula
and um it's one of those things where
the um
um I-26 gives you 25 of your daily
requirement of cholesterol cholesterol
is a required nutrient Like Oxygen right
any Doctor Who said stay away from
cholesterol should have their licenses
taken away from them
ask your doctor call up a doctor if you
have a doctor you talk to ask him what
is myelin made out of
what happens when you have a
demyelinating disease what is a
demyelinating disease oh uh MS
Alzheimer's disease Guillain-Barre
syndrome Parkinson's disease
these are all demandings these oh
how many of those people are on a
cholesterol-lowering drug a Statin drug
well they all need to be gone no none of
them do okay they got it all wrong
they're creating this monster
yeah it's it's it's something I just
I would love to have you come back
we can do it another time let's see what
response we get here yes we have um
quite a quite a list of individuals here
who are very interested in what you have
to say and we're very grateful because
what you're doing today
um is helping us for the future
generations and we're passionate about
it I apologize we got to run now yep so
thank you very much
uh thank you God bless thank you bye now
bye-bye
a lot of people were unable to get on so
that's another great reason to do the
call again at a later Point yeah it's
been recorded right yes it's been
recorded sir and I'll give you a copy of
it we need a copy of it so we can make a
tool out of it yep yep thank you thank
you Dr Wallach bye-bye yes yes